2 février 1991 au parlement le président
sud africain frederik de klerk annonce
officiellement sa volonté d'abolir
l'apartheid dans son discours inaugural
frederik de klerk s'est engagée
clairement l abolition prochaine des
trois lois fondamentales qui régissent
depuis 40 ans la discrimination raciale
loi sur l'habitat séparer loi sur la
propriété foncière et loi sur la
classification en fonction de la couleur
de peau
fondée en 1948 l'apartheid ce régime
ségrégationniste impose une séparation
stricte entre les communautés noires et
blanches
privés de droits civiques les noirs ne
sont qu'une main d'oeuvre bon marché
entassés dans des bidonvilles en fait
ils n'arrivent pas à reconnaître que
nourrit comme des êtres humains
lorsque frederik de klerk arrive au
pouvoir fin 1989
blancs et noirs vivent et travaillent
toujours séparément le 2 février 1990 le
président prend ses premières mesures
réhabilitation de la haine c'est le
parti interdit depuis 1960 restauration
de la liberté de la presse est levée
progressive de l'état d'urgence mais
surtout autre précision la libération
inconditionnelle de nelson mandela
nelson mandela condamné pour haute
trahison
libéré après 27 ans d'emprisonnement
frederik de klerk entend s'appuyer sur
le leader de l'insee pour restaurer
l'égalité raciale lines et le parti
présidentiel organise alors un
référendum le 19 mars 1992 68 7% des
électeurs blancs approuvent la politique
de démantèlement de l'apartheid est
valide
l'organisation d'élections nationales à
venir la prochaine fois les noirs et les
blancs ont voté ensemble un homme une
voix pour tout le monde ça c'est juste
fin avril 1994 premières élections
multiraciales
pendant trois jours blancs et noirs
votre ensemble
frederik de klerk savourer cet instant
historique la naissance d'un
gouvernement d'unité nationale
il représentera toute la nation les
principaux dirigeants politiques du pays
pourront travailler ensemble et assurer
la réconciliation nationale en afrique
du sud 2 mai 1994
les résultats définitifs tombe lines et
remporte 62 6% des votes
nelson mandela prend alors la tête d'une
afrique du sud unifiée après 45 ans
d'apartheid
il devient le premier président noir
[Musique]